gang just want to remind you that the ru
garbage comedy special is on our youtube
page right now it is it is our favorite
moments from last year's tour and
speaking of doors we're here to announce
2022 the middle class famous store baby
new cities new trash new money yeah gang
we're coming to hartford albany syracuse
atlanta tampa orlando pittsburgh buffalo
detroit denver phoenix salt lake city
chicago rosemont and this is just part
one plenty of cities coming after that
it's live stand up live auig it's a good
time get your tickets now we'll see you
there welcome to another exciting
edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash
now here are your hosts kevin ryan and h
foley hey everybody out there and
welcome back to everybody's favorite new
podcast this is are you garbage it's a
little show we sit down with your
favorite comedians and we find out if
they grow up to be classy or if they're
just a big old piece of trash i'm your
host stage foley coming at you on a
rainy day down here at aunt toddy's
basement she's upstairs trying to resell
the christmas tree okay trying to get a
head start all right my co-host is
coming at you from right next to me
unamused he is the ceo of ru garbage he
is an international businessman and he
is not to be trifled with in the
boardroom give it up for kippy kevin
james ryan hey gang thanks for tuning in
as always please make sure you rate
review subscribe on itunes full video
available on youtube and as you know
those numbers are true cook and baby and
then patreon.com you sign up you get a
bunch of uh bonus content live streams
the whole nine yards check it out and
having a nice quick shout out to our
producer extraordinaire the magic man
makes us all look good t-bone mcmuffin
toby mcmullen what's up dudes
it's gonna be a great episode i'm
excited it's gonna be fun very excited
because we could not be more excited to
have our incredibly and i mean
incredibly special guest here with us
today for the first time this man is a
legendary stand-up comedian actor and
director he has appeared in over 116
films and television shows and has made
over 146 stand-up and television
appearances to name but a few would be
late night with conan o'brien dr cats
three kings third watch super troopers
svu sex and the city the ellen show
hacks egg b goes down ed that 70's show
13 going on 30 pale force the love guru
flight of the concourse 17 again my boys
away we go law and order the daily show
we're not even out of the 90s
so sit back and relax
[Applause]
i got bored to death i got portlandia
kilimanjaro teacher's lounge hot pursuit
the jim gaffigan show chuck kimmy
schmidt chappaquiddick
being frank super troopers 2 hotel
transylvania 3 them that follow troop
zero drunk parents above the shadows
tesla most want it bob's burger luca
rick and morty star girl guys own comedy
central presents
he's seen him on crank yankers
conan the tonight show letterman larry
whitmore hot ones bill moore joe rogan
larry king now lights out with david
spade
james corden good morning america
colbert seth myers cbs sunday morning
and he also has multiple stand-up
specials and albums out beyond the pale
king baby mystery universe obsessed
cinco noble ape quality time and of
course the brand new comedy monster
ladies and gentlemen give it up for the
one the only
mr jim gaffney
thank you thank you i've never had ever
uh someone read every credit
that's not even old
that's uh that's very it's amazing yeah
but you know what i noticed when you
guys were introducing this i know this
is all about trash but
you're all trash
with irish names have you noticed oh
yeah it's bad the two go hand in hand
it's like
so but then it's like the question is
are you uh
lace curtain irish or
or uh trash irish which is 99 points
right now
we're gonna find out about you today my
friend i'm so nervous
what does lace curtain mean light like
fancy right lace kirk oh i thought it
meant like the little doilies that your
grandmother would have on the corner i
think that is that it is laser yeah yeah
yeah yeah but like those and we weren't
they were all cigarette burns in them oh
yeah cigarettes what an amazing
important thing because i've been trying
to write
about this it's like i remember
i don't know if this has anything to do
with your show but i remember being nine
years old and my mother sending me to
the store yeah this has a lot to do with
the show to buy a carton of cigarettes a
carton of cigarettes and when i got
there the guy wasn't like hey
you're eight years old what's going on
he was like do you need matches yeah
you want a couple beers to go with that
it was it was pretty standard of course
oh yeah it was pretty standard everyone
you know the smoking thing it's so weird
because i have all i have these kids and
they're like did you smoke and i did
smoke but i'm like i don't want to tell
them i smoked
uh so i lie cause yeah
like a good parent that's how i learn to
parent
is
through lying
but yeah no smoking both my parents
constantly smoking what was in it for
you when you would go get the cartons
because we always got a little treat if
like my mom or like one of my aunts said
run to the store and get me a couple
packs of cigarettes get yourselves a
couple of candies too well there was the
change yeah change was big as a kid the
change was a big thing where often
they'd be like you can keep the change
only if it was like changed yeah yeah
yeah no bills no real dollar bill
yeah i mean by the way it's like kids
uh you know i think i remember losing a
tooth and getting a quarter oh yeah
now they get like 20 20.
you get a bitcoin now my nieces and
nephews have like more money than me
just from like accumulating teeth and
you know graduating second grade and all
this stuff they're better with it now
too i notice my brother
and his his wife they'll
they'll start handling the funds like if
they get like something for their
birthday they have to put like 20 or
half of it in their little savings
account when we were kids it was like
smart yeah i remember my communion money
i was walking around like it was vegas
oh yeah
oh yeah
what is the origin story of mr jim
gaffigan tell us the whole deal okay
well you know i uh i'm from indiana but
i'm originally from illinois
i uh my father was from springfield
illinois
my mother was from fort dodge iowa
and um
well you know like they did i did one of
those finding your roots things which
was amazing any any dirt come up um well
i had uh there was uh my dad's name was
michael gaffigan i have a son named
michael gaffigan and there was somebody
who murdered someone who was named
michael
you never it's never you never find
anything good in these things
i don't know why anybody does it
but he was you know the thing was was he
framed because of the molly mcguire's
because the nativist thing because like
both sides of my family
were essentially
uh they fled to the midwest to escape
persecution of catholics i know that
sounds so weird
but like it's like oh there's catholics
let's get them yeah but like all these
that's why i find it so amazing when
like catholics turn around and like
percy it's like you know your grandpa
used to tell you that like
that you were picked on yeah yeah yeah i
mean it's like
so um but yes so molly mcguire's yeah
geez yeah that's crazy that's like union
cold yeah that was uh so like yeah my
father's side was big coal miner
stuff my uh
my grandfather made dentures and i
remember thinking whoa that's brutal
but then i did finding your roots and
the guy was like he was the first one to
get out of the coal mine wow
yeah better than coal mining
and so like you don't realize and so
like my
mother's family ended up in iowa because
they were in maine and they were like
lighting churches on fire and killing
like literally tauren feathering a
priest gee so they what is the 80s what
are we talking about
where is this 70s
this was like
uh 1880. all right so it's like your
mom's yeah your mom's grandparents yeah
all right yeah it wasn't like my parents
and i'd now do stand-up comedy
that'd be a shame
but it was so it's like uh so yeah but
like my father was the first one to go
to college wow but uh
you know i mean i mean i definitely grew
up upper middle class though right but
that you know like the the trash is not
far away no i mean like it's
it's a very and my parents wanted to get
away from it so like
that like that i wanted to be a farmer
they were like uh they they my mother
refused to get us where did that come
from the farmer i don't know that's it
no more vegetables in the house no it
was just a weird thing i think that it's
a midwest yeah i had a garden and it was
something you could control i don't know
i mean i was
i wasn't a bright kid
well you grow peppers now i follow you
yes yeah
so a lot of them i did it like in
sixth or seventh grade and then i didn't
do it for
30 years and now i have a garden
at the house here in the city we have uh
we rented a house in the suburbs
hate that dad i'm growing peppers yeah
so it was fun but like i'm trying to
think of like yeah so that's some of the
origins what'd your dad do my dad was a
banker your dad was a banker went the
first first one in his family to go to
college yes where did he go to school
he went to school he he was going to
become a priest okay
and then but like that was kind of a
free way to get college
oh yeah back then back then and so he uh
he went to georgetown afterwards nice
but back then georgetown wasn't that
fancy of a school you know what i mean
and so uh
yeah so like
yeah but like there was he's from
springfield i don't know if you've been
to springfield at illinois
it's you know
it's i mean it's very familiar yeah i
mean i grew up in northwest indiana
there's a lot you know
i remember the first time i performed in
chicago there were people
at the show
that
everyone who said hey i grew up in
northwest indiana they were wearing
sweatpants so it was kind of
saturday night they drove into chicago
yeah and it but like also like northwest
indiana has a
uh it's a very unique place it is
like it's the calumet region but they
identify themselves as region rats
so the northwest indiana is rejected by
chicago because it's indiana but it's
also rejected by indiana because it's
it's it's rust belt so like there's
you know a lot of these uh
different nationalities ethnic
christians whereas
indiana of the state is primarily
like protestant
whereas northwest indiana is like
ukrainian
uh eastern orthodox and greek orthodox
and irish catholic and mexican catholics
so it's
northwest indiana is a very strange
there's a strange identity there what'd
you call them rust belt rats region rats
rats and because when there were steel
mill strikes
they um
the owners of the steel mills would call
them rats they would be you know like it
was a derogatory term for strikers
but it's like a sally field movie no
this is good
but the area gets to the cocktail
yeah i mean so it is a little bit like
it's got some of that um
that blue-collar hero it's like
pittsburgh yeah yeah
that's what we're talking about yeah and
even if like you know you say you grew
up upper upper middle class yeah it's
that generation that really carries the
um you know the ways of their parents
with them i'm sure i'm sure you saw a
lot of that from your dad and how he was
raised with you know oh yeah growing up
in a much different situation yeah there
was you know like there's certain things
that
my dad had like that we didn't ha like i
can't find it anywhere like mush you
don't know what mush is i mean you guys
are more scrapple
[Laughter]
mush is like this you guys are more
stressed it's food i didn't know it was
food midwest and it's called mosh i
thought i had something in the yard
no it's mush it's like i don't you know
i honestly don't know what polenta is
but it's kind of like
it's one of those things so it was cream
of wheat fancy cream of wheat so it's
kind of like similar to grits right yeah
and so
but it was kind of like a fried thing
that you would it was like a bark kind
of thing
you keep using bad work bart and mush to
describe something to eat when you're
running from the english it's kind of
dirty yeah it was like you know
fried bologna of yeah a lot of fried
baloney my dad would make us fried
bologna for breakfast and stuff like
that how many of them were you i was the
youngest of six youngest of six families
wow and so um but you know what's weird
also is
and having traveled throughout the
united states like
we think of tamales
as
it's always about food with me we think
of tamales as
a mexican dish but surely what it
tamales is a native american dish okay
that understandably the the mexicans
also have a lot of native americans sure
and so like tamales are kind of a
midwestern thing and you'll you'll find
tamales in steakhouses in little rock
arkansas yeah there's a famous steak
place called moe's i think in little
rock
where with your steak as a side dish you
can get tamales
and i love that we gotta book a show
underneath i like it i like how he goes
like back and forth within like this
deep history of the midwest hell i love
it i love this stuff i love it
you got to go to bubbe steakhouse if you
want a really good time i'm trying to
think of like what i mean i definitely
collected
beer cans
i have uh yeah as a kid and i have a
whole thing about how
i would find these beer cans walking
home from school which tells you how
nice the town was
you know what i mean and i didn't bring
them to a recycling center i put them on
a shelf in my bedroom
my parents were aware of this yeah right
um
there was also
i mean this is uh
you know in my like
definitely see like you grew up you guys
grew up on the east coast like in the
midwest
italian food
so obviously there's a lot of italians
in chicago but like in northwest indiana
there wasn't that many like there were
enough where there were restaurants but
it was pretty much considered ethnic
food yeah yeah yeah italian food back in
the day would your mom make an attempt
at spaghetti and meatballs
she would do spaghetti with meat sauce
but it was just ground beef you know i
mean so like like i was a little shocked
when like by the way there's mexicans in
northwest indiana but like i was kind of
shocked when
mexican like when you ordered a beef
taco for a mexican taco and it was like
kind of the string beef you're like i
didn't ask for a sloppy joe
ground beef yeah yeah yeah right and so
i don't even know how i got on that
topic but like just how like
italian food
was foreign to you it was a it was you
know we definitely had spaghetti but we
didn't call
we didn't know what pasta was yeah like
pasta that was yeah that was definitely
fancy you'd have penny a lavaca right
yeah
i remember when i was in college i had a
roommate sophomore year we were both uh
and
he was like what's the best thing your
mom makes and i was like her spaghetti
and he goes and i said what's your best
thing your mom makes and he said baked
uh ziti and i was like what's that
it was a dessert or something
you don't know what ziti is and i'm like
i've never heard of it
and i had never eaten short noodles
i mean so what's this pizza i keep
hearing about but obviously there was
pizza yeah yeah yeah and you know some
of it is like when i was a kid
and i see it with my teenagers you don't
pay attention that's what we're i'm
learning from the show he's we ask
questions about dinner i'm like i don't
i didn't know anything my mom made i
just ate it or i didn't eat it yeah it
was just you know you don't pay
attention i'm sure i was in a restaurant
that had ziti but i didn't see it
did your mom by any chance to do the
spaghetti in a skillet
i don't know afterwards oh do you mean
the second round of it yes no no but my
wife's uh mother dead yeah very old
school my aunt did that a lot
as irish as they come and we cut it up
it was so good it was so weird when you
would go to like friend's house
because like
when we would have spaghetti it was
you got too much of it
and then you'd go to a friend's house
and they're like they give you like a
salad bowl version of spaghetti with
just the sauce on just the corner of the
noodles you're like what the hell what
are we doing here yeah like this is not
spaghetti where are we are we in japan
here i mean it's like you know anything
yeah
it's got to be big
i'm trying to think of like what was
what was the house that you guys lived
in how many bedrooms and how many of you
were in there at the same time i always
had uh a roommate until people started
moving out okay
a roommate you mean
my brother yeah it was like you were
taking a stranger travelers yeah some
rents are passing through
uh but i'm trying to think of like
there's like there was a lot of uh
i remember being a little kid oh i gotta
get to the fishing thing i brought this
up yeah that's great so this is uh a
true detail of my childhood which i
don't know if it's white trash or if
it's
um
just kind of an experience that i had
the first time i went fishing i'm not
making this up
was in the community swimming pool
every september they would fill the
public pool with fish and chlorine and
then kids from the town would try and
catch the fish
before the chlorine killed the fish
it was a race against the clock
and there is a photo of when i was like
so i'm the youngest of all these
siblings and as my sister pam
had gotten all these uh everyone to
gather all their fish together to give
to me so that i would
be in the newspaper
for like catching the most fish it was
also the same for the most poisoned fish
yeah i mean like the easter egg hunt i
had like you know crates of eggs but
like i didn't pick them it was just my
sister was all set up
for the family yeah she should have been
a publicist yeah right yeah
but i'm trying to think of like this
would you eat the fish
no no no i no i did not
that's to this day
that's also i think a sign of
uh garbage is
fish is you don't eat fish like fish
and i know you guys east coast people
you eat fish what about friday during
lent didn't you guys have to have fish
we i mean we had fileta fish
but like mcdonald's was a big shout out
to gordon's i mean this is how old i am
like i remember
there were times where my parents would
give us each a dollar and we would walk
to mcdonald's
and you could walk to mcdonald's you
could get a burger and fries and then
walk to dairy queen
with 30 cents and get a cone for 25
cents this was in 1902
1902 but it was where's the horses
i remember when candy bars were 10 cents
you guys are like i don't remember that
they're like he wishes he was born 50
years ago i got lost in a fantasy
i got to figure out how to make a time
machine real quick
get my get over to dairy queen
gabby how about that mint mobile mint
mobile you know about them
using them for a while big mint mobile
household over there at the uh ryan
residence you're just finding out about
them do yourself a favor get on that
mint mobile 15 bucks a month pass the
savings right on to you you're probably
like oh there's got to be a hook there's
got to be a thing there's not there's no
middleman direct to the consumer if
saving more than spending less is one of
your top goals for 2022 uh why are you
still paying insane amounts of money
every month for wireless knock it off
like the big man said mobile just 15
bucks a month uh my wife uses mint
mobile they send it to us she reboots it
with that card bada bing bada boom keeps
the phone the number the whole nine
yards it's fantastic to get your new
wireless plan for just 15 bucks a month
and get the plan shipped right to your
door for free go to mintmobile.com
garbage that's mint mobile.com garbage
cut your wireless bill to 15 bucks a
month at mintmobile.com garbage gang
let's talk about the good folks over
there at movement movement people at
college dropouts couple of go-getters
got into the watch in the sunglass
business and bang it took off yeah
absolutely fantastic i got a watch i got
some sunglasses and i love them to death
and i tell you what you know what
they're focusing on now what's that they
got those blue sunglasses when you're
scrolling on the screen ever scroll get
your eyes all goofy yeah you got to get
in there you got to protect yourself
that stuff will jam you up blue light
can be super harsh on your eyes and some
studies show that has too much exposure
to blue light may lead to disrupted
sleep patterns and other health effects
that's why movement ever scrolls are
game changers your eyes will thank you
if you're sitting in a computer and sit
in front of a computer all day get these
bad boys yes you got to take care of
yourself protection baby uh crafted with
top tier materials movement ever scrolls
filter out nearly 90 of the most intense
blue light rays and feature anti-glare
lenses for elevated comfort these are
top of the line top of the line
state-of-the-art state-of-the-art if you
want to protect your eyes with style
that doesn't break the bank join the
movement and get 15 off today with free
shipping and free returns by going to
mvmt.com garbage again one more time
write it down that's mvmt.com
garbage do it but i want to remember
more i'm trying to think of like what
else there was you know it was just
like growing up in indiana what was the
because i i've lived in chicago for a
long time so all i know of indiana is
fireworks yeah so what was like the
firework bb gun slingshot situation a
lot of outdoor what were you well there
was um
there was definitely a lot of fireworks
stores because it was a little bit you
know people would come and buy fireworks
there so like here's what i always i
have whenever i perform in chicago i
always bring this up
like
being you know i grew up
half an hour from chicago
in northwest indiana and so but whenever
i'm in chicago like people in chicago
and i'm exaggerating obviously they
don't know anything about indiana so
you're you're like i'm from india and
they're like
where's that
when's your flight get here
away
they asked for your passport you're like
i thought that was the road to michigan
and it is you know because people would
drive through indiana to get to a
vacation place in michigan would you
guys go into the city as a family we
would go shopping uh you know
i'm thinking more as a teenager to uh
would go to watertower place to go
shopping okay a big shopping mall we'd
go in for the saint patrick's day parade
they would die the river green
um
you know you would you know like also as
a high school student you go and get
wasted
i remember i was so this is where my dad
would wanted us to be fancy like you
have to understand also like
in chicago at the time the cubs played
during the day and the white stars
played at night were
they were like a
a level of trash you can't even
comprehend
like it was the circus
and there was like
there was you know like you walk around
the city and you smell weed like that's
what it was like to be at a white sox
game
so my dad one time
he brought us to a white sox game and i
don't know why but he had us wear ties
and so we're at a white sox game and
people in front of us
are smoking weeds it's like anything
it's like a fight like i don't know if
you've ever have you ever been to the
meadowlands well you guys are from
philly so of course you know this it's
like there is this described
thanksgiving in my house there's a
tribalism that comes out in certain of
course athletic um
and so like comiskey park was very much
like
you're going into a certain level of
chaos and at that time i mean i just
kind of helped you yeah no
but i think that was
them wanting to be a classic be higher
than they are yes my dad definitely
wanted that and so like
and all my siblings rebelled you know
like so my brother mike the first car he
bought was a pickup truck and my parents
were like what did we do we're not pick
up trucks people you know and so
yeah it's weird there's a little bit of
a mix
like did you read uh hillbilly elegy
like there's uh so you guys are trash
you don't read
it's probably one of the most famous
books for the past 10 years you guys
never heard of it is that by larry the
cable guy or something what's happening
you're like wait a minute how many
pictures in this book
is that a coloring book does it come
with crayons i'm more of a sports
illustrated man yeah
that sports illustrated that they got
rid of that issue right swimsuit issue
not that i've
noticed yeah but
not that i've written angry letters mr
illustrator that blew you guys away oh
my gosh the for you guys are the first
one to get that oh it was just
unbelievable yeah
he just went back to the 80s
it was a different era it's a different
era
it was a strange time i mean i remember
when
um
you know the uh victorious secret
catalog
came out that was that was big news that
was like holy [ __ ] see you guys later
i mean pre-internet that's you know
you're like
you're like well there i guess you know
like your mom you're like she didn't
order this i guess there is a god
it just showed up yeah i want to go back
real quick just because it's stuck in my
head about the fish
about you didn't you don't eat fish you
do now right
not really i mean you've been all over
the world i wish i had to have tried all
right
look i like
i like halibut i like
tuna but it's a weird one to say by the
way i've never heard anybody with
halibut what's that i don't know i just
never heard it
oh really yeah i guess that's another
post thing too maybe and uh
no i just know halibut is a white fish
and also it's like when we i remember i
did uh
a cruise ship when i was dating my wife
in alaska it was like through um from
vancouver to alaska you were working
yeah i was working right
and um
and i was like all right i'm gonna i'm
gonna try salmon like she's i mean she's
from milwaukee she ate fish you know and
she used to kind of give me [ __ ] she's
like what's wrong with you with fish and
i'm like it smells like a butt i don't
know on top
then i can understand but now
i know no i know but like and then i
also i did a bunch of material
i don't know if this has happened to you
guys where you do material on something
and then that influences you like i used
to eat
i mean i think oysters are disgusting
yeah oh man that's because you like to
eat [ __ ]
hey the kids got me i don't know what to
tell you
right
cocktail sauce
no but um
isn't he the clean comedian yeah i need
that just for my i need that clip just
for my personal but uh
yeah no like i i like shrimp uh you know
my aunt lived in maryland i definitely
ate crabs all right there you go but um
like uh you know i've done too much
material on seafood now i'm kind of like
i can barely do lobster i can do it here
and there but like
like you know like i think that i'm good
for it i'm like okay we're i'm gonna get
fish tacos look at me go everyone and
then i'm like it smells good
it's like i'm such a baby i'm like
where's the where's that sauce they put
on in san diego where you can't tell
it's fish
[Laughter]
it it's uh if it's deep fried fish tacos
it's chicken fried if it's deep fried
fish
yeah fish and chips i'm fine with that
so you won't do you want the oysters in
the half shell you won't do what about
sushi i'll do a spicy tuna
all right um it's an irish thing you
know
my family is like yeah it is
irish people especially back then were
like simple simple people it's like yeah
you know oh so thank you for that
compliment
you're like simple
dumb idiot
no you remind me of like an absolute
imbecile
salmon what kind of dog is that
no but if you say like your parents and
parents it's just like you know it's in
you to not be i think my parents liked
fish i think i think it's
and again i
i wish i liked salmon but like like
caviar do you like caviar i would never
eat i've only had a little bit of it
i've been wanting to try when you were
in paris
back to my podcast of being salt of the
earth i was in paris
in paris it was only a five-star hotel
no gaffing and just put two in the back
of your head
that's the end of the show i thought
this was gonna be a fun episode
gathering comes in and ruins it the
first time i've traveled what do you
want from me
it was paris texas it was in paris
it was in paris with olivia wilde and
we're dancing
oh that's so funny it was at timothy
charlemagne's house
enjoying some caviar you shared a peach
with him
did you see that movie i watched that
movie on a plane
and i was like
i'm like
you know like there's still the remnants
of like the eighth grade homophobia like
yeah
it would get to the game part and i'd be
like fast forward not into this
because i want to play not into this hey
7b
i got the victoria's secret catalog next
to me i'm imagining women
oh good
what's what was the summer job situation
i worked in a grocery store nice
uh it was uh i also
was it the grocery store that your mom
went to no it was it was uh
farther away
uh my dad got me the job there
nice so i also worked uh i worked
construction
uh my dad got me that job
i and one summer my dad couldn't get me
a job so he made me volunteer at the
hospital okay so i was like is he kind
of a mover and shaker in in in the town
he in some ways i think bankers you know
he was he would describe himself as a
small town banker but like i think
he yeah he definitely had some influence
sure you know so but like i am grateful
that i had those opportunities i
remember when i was doing construction
again i the only reason i got the job is
because of my dad but like
there was a time during the summer when
they
it became a uh
firsthand knowledge that i was a college
student and like people that were super
nice to me were just like done yeah
really yeah oh yeah
man
job sites are tough tough cookies out
there yeah
midwest yeah thanks
all right let's get a little uh little
are you garbage questions here okay um
obviously the family doesn't still live
in the same hat nobody lives in the same
house you grew up in right now
so what was the name of the street that
you grew up on
um uh hill road
sounds pretty classy it's all right yeah
the cul-de-sacs in the neighborhood
uh no it was it was i'm not gonna act
like it wasn't a nice area it was nice
it was a nice area it was a nice how
many bedrooms
um
[Music]
six kids six kids four
all right five nice five pool do you
guys do a pool no no pool no pool garage
um uh no it was like an under area where
you could park like an overhang type
carport yeah i gotcha i gotcha okay
that's the point where it's like oh this
bastard
this carport having an sop when i was in
paris i would see these people
i'm just down to earth in paris
what was the name of the grocery show
that your mom went to as a kid i don't
know is it piggly wiggly
little it was not in paris my friend i
can tell you that when i was very little
it was jewel i remember it all right
there you go
that's close but i think oh by the way
also
there all right in my town where i lived
we did not get a mcdonald's
until i was in high school
we had
a
dairy queen yeah that was open just for
the summer
and now they have everything yeah yeah
they are not too shabby either their
burgers ain't bad yeah so but like it
was not a brazier it was not a dairy
queen brazier it was just a dairy just
the ice cream what does brazier mean i
think brazier means french
you should look it up when you were in
france i'll have the frosting with
timothy chalamet
it's so weird you have you're like i got
in here and he's like shows me photos of
like these nude photos of timmy i know
it was crazy he was like look at timothy
and i'm like i think it's timothy and he
goes not to me
i call him tim tim
[Laughter]
wait if you guys didn't have mcdonald's
would you have culvers
no not yet no um where are you getting a
burger from
well we would you know it's weird we so
we kind of moved in eighth grade but
like the best burger in northwest
indiana is this burger called shoops
which is yeah it's so good and to this
day it's my favorite burger um but in
that area we would drive to uh we would
drive to another town to see a movie we
would
you know like i'm sure there was like
there was a burger king in michigan city
okay you know what i mean um but yeah
they didn't have like then they had a
shoes in
michigan city later on
but um shoot sounds awesome yeah it
sounds good it's you go back as it's
still around
yeah when you're there yes yeah and like
uh yeah it's that good it's that good
gotta add that to the list
what there was all right i can't
remember it okay what about the vacation
the family vacation situation family
vacation i love how you're writing this
down like it's like all right you're
like a detective you're like
did you get to the bottom of this gym
the easy way or the hard way you choose
it should be that should be uh it should
be you guys as law and order detectives
um
we went on get the phone books let's see
vacations uh we definitely we would
drive to my uncle joe's for thanksgiving
every year but like
i definitely went on i went on a big
vacation
to europe
when i was in
i don't know i was like 10. that's cool
i think it's really cool my grandmother
passed away and i think
my parents were like let's do it so they
uh we went where'd you go
i went to ireland
greece i saw the first time i saw a
man and a thong uh on uh in greece
um and then where else did we go
oh copenhagen
ah all right it's pretty cool that's a
pretty classy vacation yeah that's very
classy what about disney world at
disneyland as a kid
i went to disney world i think once okay
and i remember i think i threw up when i
got there
all the excitement
the whole way
i think that we also went to um
hilton head once and i think i almost
drowned
um a tough run of fake
i got a concussion at busch gardens yeah
i'm trying to think you know as so i'm
the youngest also so like as my parents
as people moved out they
they did more yeah
less kids to watch a couple more bucks
laying down yeah were you ever in the
house by yourself was it ever just you
and everybody was already off at college
and stuff like that yeah yeah that was
rough
that's very rough you know the youngest
of six kids your kids your parents are
mentally ill
[Laughter]
yeah and by then they're just all over
you they know every trick or you know i
think
well they you know i used to have a joke
about that like in my uh about how when
you're the youngest of six kids your
parents have seen everything and they
don't
it's like you're not going out tonight
you'll end up pregnant like your sister
yeah i mean it's like
just they've been lied to you
and so i would go into the garage and
lift weights and i would come back and
my dad would be like what were you
really doing and i'd be like covered in
sweat
having lifted weights and i'm like i
lifted weights and he's like
likely yeah let me smell your breath
gang let's talk about babel apple babble
babble let me tell you something learn a
new language it's fun it's exciting i
knew a little bit of french when i got
over there and i'm telling you it made
the difference yeah feel smarter i know
you gotta be able to stick and move a
little bit bonjour shoe oh bollywood
wine where are the hot
dogs donde esta los cervicios por favor
yikes you gotta get on the babble gang
yeah the whole battle process is
addictively fun and easy babel teaches
bite-sized language lessons for
real-world use i've actually used it in
the past before they were even a sponsor
really when i go when i when i you know
as my my ladies german so i'm trying to
war i trying to where i had a you know
german poetry it is it's nice it's fun
um
other language uh learning apps use ai
for the lessons plan but babbles less
than babel lessons were created by over
100 language experts with babel you can
choose from 14 different languages
including spanish french italian and
german plus babel speech recognition
technology helps you to improve your
pronunciation and accent and you want to
watch out for that ai i don't trust it
nah remember terminator
i'm not i'm not messing with it no right
now when you purchase the three month uh
babel subscription you'll get an
additional three months for free look at
that you get an additional three months
that's six months for the price of three
just go to babel.com use promo code
garbage that's b a b b e l dot com code
garbage babble language for life do it
manscape that's what we're talking about
man escaped let me ask you something
yeah folks at manscape want to ask you
something what are the balls like down
here yeah are they stinky is it hairy
you got a rainforest you got swamp going
on what are you doing you got to clean
it up man you got to keep it tight it's
a game changer you know the game changer
comes in is when you use that manscape
4.0 when you get the lawn mower on the
grass then you hop in the shower
and you start you know
going down just you just you know see
what's going on yeah it do you feel like
a million bucks feels like a different
person down there yeah i don't mind
guys the performance package 4.0 you'll
find the signature lawnmower 4.0 the
electric trimmer that probably that has
proprietary advanced skin safe
technology to reduce cuts on your nuts
ceramic you got the light you got the
powerful motor but quiet it's awesome
plus they got they'll throw in a crop
preserver uh anti-chafing ball deodorant
moisturizer and toner it's time to keep
your north pole smelling fresh you know
it's an underrated hit over there too is
they got a foot spray yeah also got a
two-in-one shampoo and conditioner which
has key ingredients and benefits that
include hydrating nourishing
conditioning the scalp strengthening
your hair all at the same time nice get
20 off plus free shipping with code
garbage at manscape.com get you one more
time 20 off free shipping with the code
garbage at manscape.com that's free
shipping manscape.com promo code garbage
clean up your nuts that a
now back to the show back to the show
but my older siblings were you know
there were a troublesome bunch well
you're not oh boozing in high school and
stuff like that yeah yeah
yeah i boost i didn't smoke that much i
uh that was still kind of taboo-ish
right
um
but yeah no the drinking thing was
definitely and there was no moderation
it was just like
just
ridiculous amounts the governor's office
like i think i got drunk and in trouble
um
in eighth grade
yeah
that's young yeah
yeah i feel like it is like very midwest
though i feel like you guys start a
little early you're just like i mean i
don't know it changes so it's similar to
stand-up you know like there's some
is something that happens
and then people are like oh that's how
it works and then six months later
they're like no no over here hbo max is
doing this yeah you're like this is
paramount
[Laughter]
they just asked me for it you know i
mean
where were you six months ago they're
like well i went to all these open mics
like nah that doesn't matter that
doesn't count anymore
now when you go on vacation now like or
like travel for work would you take your
kids with you i try to show them the
world and stuff like that definitely
yeah i've seen that yo you're always
taking everybody everywhere yeah and
it's uh
and during each of those trips and we've
been amazing places there's always
incredible memories there's always a
moment where i look at my kids and i
think
i'm never doing this
it's just too hard
it's because i'll do shows so then i'll
have to push people out of the room
so that i wish i was one of those
comedians that
doesn't prepare
you jeremy or just like you know what i
just show up but i'm like i'm like uh
somebody who has to study i have a
a bad short-term memory and so i'm
always kind of and if you can think of
one line
yeah it's worth it yeah yeah so uh yeah
so it's tough to do that with people
hanging around yeah you know especially
if you have to be dad at the time as
well yes and then also i like to nap
because i'm a grandpa
i'm a big believer in naps do you guys
naps i do come on i got a sleep apnea
machine coming so i'm hoping that's
going to fix it cause i got i got sleep
apnea really bad and how did you find
out you had that because i was dying
every every every 30 seconds while i was
sleeping i would just wait i would wake
up and feel like i was having a heart
attack
and then finally my i was sleeping
timothy
that's who told him originally we sleep
in separate bedrooms oh that's very
moderate yeah very french very parisian
but yeah but i take that but sometimes a
nap is makes it worse doesn't it
never
not for me
my wife can't nah
but uh i mean i could nap right here
really yeah i'm gonna do it right now
no i'm a big napper like oh i enter a
room and i'm like i could nap on that
couch yeah you start scoping it out what
do you get i mean you are
a you are a busy man yes you work your
ass off what do you get at night on a
regular basis and even is there a
regular basis there you know but
i mean it's
the problem is i have material on this
too it's like
my wife is a non-sleeper too
so i am somebody
uh if i wasn't doing stand-up i could
probably be in bed by 10. okay but
i i probably go to sleep at one and get
up i do the morning shift so i get up at
six
one to six so you need a nap yeah and so
yeah
falling asleep everywhere and so then i
uh you know it's five kids
and
they're
monsters so
and they're not they don't wake up i
mean i would say my youngest kind of
like hey how are you in the morning but
the rest of them are like you touch me
i'll kill you
i hate you dad yeah so it is
it's yeah it's that morning shift is
hard i mean of course it's like a
fraction of what my wife does but anyway
i'm a great guy
i'm pretty fantastic
when you do sleep what's the uh what's
the pillow situation
fan directly on you anything like that i
have uh gone to i sleep face down
no you don't what's wrong that's kind of
weird
[Laughter]
if you're a dead mobster nothing it's
like a dirt nap in the air
i sleep well we're talking about we got
a kick right we got a king king we got a
king all right i uh i hold on to a
pillow that's shaped like a dick
no
a pillow
uh just because i'm so fat i think i
need i do it too yeah yeah this is
you're laying flat on your face not like
his face you're on your stomach it's
like you're like lying down there's like
okay all right you know
[Applause]
what you lie on your back no never i'm
on my side is that you're trying to say
your st i pictured you like this yeah
with your face in the pillow yeah i
don't know you know it's like there is
something it's like it's
like that means you were
raped repeatedly as a child i don't know
what it means it definitely does i know
that that my issues are definitely
come out when i sleep i have to have a
pillow between my legs i'm like
clutching one hugging one yeah what is
that about we're crazy that's what it's
about or we're just fat guys that yeah
you need it to prop you up in certain
angles i think yeah that's what i think
it is by the way i'm
i now when i wake up it's like
i can't go back to sleep sometimes yeah
oh it's the worst it's the worst you
guys keep the tv on
yeah my wife um
which is a horrible thing tv's on all
night
uh often well we'll deal with dvr thing
so then it'll turn to like that any
lights on in the room no i don't like
lights no
fan
uh i like it cult i like it very cold
but my wife doesn't
who wins that
yeah well i mean she'll just be like
it's freezing and i'm like i know thank
god yeah that's what i was going for
i love it when it's cool but also she
had this medical condition so
she'll cough repeatedly
during the night
uh
and she'll sound like she stops
breathing so and
so i'll have that panic yeah yeah and
also when you have kids you have like
this super hearing where you're like
you hear like a certain cry you're like
what is that you know is someone
murdering my children
you know that kind of thing
sounds like a good time yeah it's very
relaxing
all right growing up did you growing up
endor now and i guess your kids do you
do milk with dinner
i think growing up i definitely yeah
sure growing up i did a lot of bologna
sandwiches with
ketchup
um i also by the way so for my
seventh birthday my sister pam
bought me um
a package of hot dogs
and a six-pack of dr pepper oh my god
that is the trashiest gift i've ever
heard in my life and i was excited
the next year
like when i was ten she bought me a hot
air popcorn maker i love i still love
popcorn
um but i'm trying to think of what hot
dogs is a gift it was a six pack of dr
pepper and it was oscar meyer hot dogs
it was like but it was
so but yeah it was one of those things
where like this because being the
youngest of six kids
the food was gone
you know you would food would enter the
house
you know and things would be gone i
would also eat a lot of uh
like after school i would eat pieces of
bread
i would take a piece of wonder bread i
don't know if you guys had wonder bread
yeah of course and you tear the sides
off and then you take the bread and you
fold it and you fold it until it's like
a little dough cube oh yeah we were
talking about this
we made them in a little ball yeah yeah
yeah um were you allowed sugar cereal in
your house when you guys were kids not
really right not really uh what was the
go-to box in the house i think it was i
think it was uh corn flakes it was
pretty much cornflour
it was also one of those things where
the cereal would be gone yeah it would
be gone so like and also i had an older
brother mike who would beat you up if
you ate the cereal
so i was like you pig
and so you'd be like i only had one bowl
there's none in here
so it was very much that what about the
pet situation
we had dogs uh we i had a dog buttons
um and uh
buttons uh
i don't know why that makes me laugh we
think he sounds like he was
italian
buttons no jimmy
hey buttons how about a walk huh
[Laughter]
buttons who by the way nobody washed so
he smelled
it's like our buttons and buttons
buttons was probably poisoned by a
neighbor really really he had a heart
attack right in front of me it was the
most dramatic thing she probably is
probably 13 at the time was there a beef
with the neighbor or something
no it was i think they were just dealing
with raccoons and they put out something
oh
and um and then
so my
dad went to georgetown
met my mom at georgetown she was at a
day school it was all men then
and so then my parents after buttons
passed away and it was totally
my dog so they surprised me and they got
another dog and they called it hoyo
which is the name of the georgetown team
i my brother joe who's kind of my irish
twin rent went to georgetown the next
year i applied i didn't get in not only
did i not get in
i applied to like six colleges didn't
get into one of them really
so and then there was this dog as this
reminder yeah you stink yeah yeah so i
poisoned them
i'll have the last laugh
this is for buttons
but anyway you did end up going to
georgetown right i did i transferred in
wait yeah what you started to
do playing ball
well i really didn't really
but still it's division one it's purdue
yeah i mean i didn't do the whole season
so it's like i don't want to be
dishonest you know i mean it was just
like
i was a lineman and i and they're like
you're not
going to gain weight
and i'm like
if only they knew
see me in 20 years right
there's a picture of you floating around
where you're like jack yeah you're like
did you play you played in high school
obviously i played in high school and
then i played george first time
this kid's pretty good he's a natural
um but yeah i was i wrestled in high
school
and i remember at the weigh-ins i don't
know if anyone wrestled did anyone
wrestle of course it was so weird the
the weigh-ins everyone's naked naked
naked
and so what would i would have this so i
was
completely cut and i was also the
whitest thing on earth so at the
weigh-in the guy would be like what the
[ __ ] where's gavin
so it was this intimidating thing or i
like to think that it was
you know like this really intimidating
guy who was just oddly white
so yeah can't get a read on him
huh i like it any magicians are
inventors in your family
no magicians okay when you order take
out food now will you like plate it or
were you eating out of the container
um i would just eat it out of the
container my wife will play it if you
guys get chinese for dinner at the house
yeah for the kids everyone's getting the
plate
we had thai food last night but um yeah
some of it is sharing
yeah you know but the two younger kids
they just eat rice by the way here's
another white trash thing
um
so far everything is
[Laughter]
by the way growing up
when we would get when we would have
chinese food by the way there were no
chinese people in our town
um
and so it was like it was made up
chinese yeah and but also we would get
rice and then
someone would go in the kitchen and we'd
put butter on the rice and we'd eat that
that's authentic trash yeah you guys
didn't do butter on your sandwiches did
you on your bread no i there were people
that i remember i went to a friend's
house
and there was a peanut butter and jelly
sandwich and the mom put peanut butter
butter
on i've seen that that's a good woman
really you love that oh my god that's a
very european thing my aunt well i can't
remember the paris what do you expect
yeah you're in the shower man
no when i was a kid my aunt put it was
it would be ham and cheese it would the
bread would always be buttered
always and so you wouldn't use
mayonnaise sometimes it would be
mayonnaise as well oh wow that's that's
a lot that's a lot going on are you a
mayonnaise guy i am a huge man are you
are you a mayonnaise uh and your french
fries guy
um i have done it i'm not opposed to it
not a present i'm not ant i'm in the
neighborhood sure um but yeah
like the uh and you know like even my
resistance to the butter on
i'm also a salted butter guy are you a
salted butter are you playing course you
gotta go salted well you know i think
high-end people uncertain it's trash
what are we doing it doesn't taste like
anything yeah it's like that's why we're
here like an extra salted by the way
growing up
um
had no idea what hummus was i mean i
don't think anyone i just found out
about that a couple of weeks no one knew
what hummus we didn't know what balsamic
vinegar was i swear to god until about
2004. well in my house i think italians
definitely did right of course that's
their go-to why are they so good at food
i don't know they're good they just
dominate because we were our our answers
were too busy
like getting boozed up and fighting
would you guys do a traditional st
patrick's day corned beef cabbage we
would do uh we you know corned beef and
cabbage which by the way is something
that the irish stole from the germans of
course um lower east side correct but
yeah
and uh thieves
but they
we did occasionally i mean corned beef
is not my thing really
not a fan of it um pastrami i love
pastrami it's one of my favorite things
interesting um
that's right you are a katz's guy yeah
i'm a huge guy it's this guy but like
but i also like seven at second avenue
deadly but the uh what about sargeras
you do sarge's i don't know if i've done
that is that on the upper west side no
36th and second or 36th and third i
don't know if i've been there good stuff
yeah but um
the uh but we did
look for leprechauns after dinner
like
that was just to get us outside sure go
out get out of the house go look for
leprechauns i got one your mom's like
what the [ __ ] the neighbor you're like
let's go look for a leprechaun all right
definitely had a guinness by the time i
was
i think i probably had a beer with my
dad when i was 12. wow wow that was
young 12. yeah how old were you when you
had your first cigarette
uh
i snuck one when i was like 16.
that's
yeah that's about yeah this might be a
deeper i hated it too i mean i hated the
fact that my parents smoked not because
i was like it's unhealthy it was just
like i didn't like the smell that's
bothersome this might be i chewed
tobacco did you chew tobacco no what i
i'm addicted to the nicotine gum are you
chewing nicotine going right now i think
he has two pieces oh my god that's a big
piece there's more than one piece in
there man he pulled it out of his pocket
i thought it was dayquil i didn't
realize it i didn't know this is
nicotine no but yes so uh nicotine gum
uh but yeah no i dipped copenhagen
uh which is an american boy over here
and uh
the key key dip is
that our keystone that was that's really
that's the that's the real that's
another level
but uh
yeah no i remember i was probably 13
when i had an older brother who
uh had me try copenhagen i almost fell
over yeah
and i loved it
i'm in heaven that happens i gotta take
me now because i got a buzz yeah yeah i
i hate a newport when i was like 13 that
just put me on the moon
it was crazy right ah i felt like i was
in jefferson airplane
it's not even safe it's nice and then
you chase it for another 20 years yeah
and you never get it you never get it
it's funny i mentioned this before but
you'll connect with this uh i went to
catholic school when i was a kid but for
for a minute for one year we went to
like a um
uh like a more eastern european orthodox
catholic catholic school yeah and their
host wasn't a piece of you know the
wafer it was a little teaspoon of wine
with a little piece of bread in it and
they would give that to us
at communion on like thursday morning
and dude i would be like i'd be all
banged up for the next two periods and
like i remember i put two and two
together i was like oh this is wine i'm
drunk and i like this
wow and then i would just get real
sleepy
and then you would and then
then suddenly you'd be called to the
guidance counselor
uh and the guidance counselor would be
like why don't you lie down
what about um hold on while we were
talking about butter growing up under
now butter on the counter or in the
fridge great question this is a big one
on the on the pod we always did butter
in the fridge my wife is from wisconsin
where they leave butter out what do you
prefer do you have a preference i like
it i felt it i like i like i can't
believe your parents didn't have it on
the counter old school irish you got to
be kidding me no it's like it was
it was too many flies i think
or they didn't have a cover or i don't
know but now that it's soft you can just
start spreading it
it's the worst when you're like because
i love toast yeah and then you have to
pick up a bar i mean there's probably
worse things like i imagine slavery
might have been
there
i'm ripping my bread
[Laughter]
oh my god how do you think i feel
look at this thing
i'm struggling
uh where does the peanut butter go in
the cabinet or in the fridge uh
growing up the cabinet right now
now i think my wife puts it in the
fridge well really
always a hot that's gotta rip the bread
always a hunch that's gonna rip them
always the hunts family oh it's a hunt
oh no no always
yeah
by the way helmets but we i think there
was some miracle whip in there that's
crazy that's that's miracle whip is just
it's like by the way miracle whip and
fluff they're not that different no
they're comparing
definitely made in the same factory and
i don't like it
yeah uh you've traveled all over the
country known foo guy is there a
regional cuisine that you haven't been
affinity for like skyline chili or deep
dish pizza anything that stands out oh
well i i mean deep dish pizza is one of
my favorite things we had we were in
chicago for a family reunion uh for for
christmas
and that's what we had for uh christmas
dinner eat dish pizza what oh my god my
wife was not thrilled no amount of world
tours can make you classy um
it was no it was uh it wasn't open
uh you know i like lou malnati's
what's that it wasn't gino's east was it
no no but juno's uh east
everything was closed so it was
pequots or piquanza's fire that's a good
choice yeah
here's a question i just thought of that
that'll work for you are there any pizza
places in new york city that has a
picture of you hanging on the wall
eating a piece of pizza with the owner
there's gotta be you gotta be no i don't
think so you gotta be you're not
you're not in john's or anything by the
way um
what's the one that's uh
god i should know that we had a wedding
re uh not wedding reception
[Applause]
dominoes on 38th street
but where's the chuck e cheese
at um
lombardi's
before before they'd switch lombardi's
used to be just
part of it and then they had this room
and we rented out the room it was like
we paid for the wedding and uh my wife's
one of nine kids so it was like
there was a lot and we did it in new
york city and so uh and i'm a cheap
bastard so we did it like that
pepperoni what do you wanna answer
i'm not paying for your pepperoni i need
two slices of plain over here we're in
the weeds you're getting planted you're
keeping it there put these calzones over
here
i'm not paying for that uh you have a
garlic now you can't totally get
garlic the wedding cakes garlic nuts
how do you feel about uh brushing your
teeth in the shower
i don't do that
do you pee in the shower uh no really no
i mean i have an aristocracy
if you had to have a go-to frozen pizza
what would it be and do we do that at
the house now with the kids
not really you're watering out new york
city um and by the way it's not like
what you'd think it's
domino's is pretty easy hey buddy you're
you know
big dominance you're preaching
awesome also my wife likes the thin
crust yeah thin crust is great on there
and you can eat like three of those
literally you know they rush them and
they're like sixty dollars so you're
like why am i getting this again when
there is world-class pizza a block away
sometimes it just hits the spot
um have you ever made nachos in the
microwave
yeah definitely yeah all right that's my
kind of guy i definitely make by the way
i my wife
is from wisconsin and so like
being exposed to like
that cheese
culture
it changed me forever so
you were only a couple hundred miles
away no but
jupiter i mean we had people had sharks
growing up like chicago land people even
showers like did you guys have
brownworks yeah we have skilbasa kilbasa
that's not the same thing like a
bratwurst is like heaven a kill boss is
like all right i'm hungry
i don't know he just defended every
position yeah i've had both i think i'm
a kilbasa man
it's too hot it's like biting it it's
like biting through skin i guess you
like it
[Laughter]
it's got a nice snap to it what i'm
saying like there is a snap it's a
little fleshy yeah but by the way i love
pierogies of course i love pierogies
this is tease frozen pearls yeah yes do
you cook at the house i do yeah during
the lockdown person i cooked a lot i'm
not good at it but i uh i would
and then i grew all these peppers and
they were all like they were all great
so i put hot peppers in everything what
do you want a hot pepper omelette what
do you guys think
my kids are like what the hell
dad what's in the opinion
this spaghetti is so hot i'm like it's
good for you
who wants some habanero pudding
[Laughter]
i love it
all right i think i'm pretty much oh
yeah maybe a couple of more i got for
you but i mean i think we got him dead
the rights here um have you ever skied
in jeans
oh yeah oh god
you answered that too calmly and
confidently well there was
there was i mean first of all
i mean like
there's certain things like skiing
horseback riding
i don't like
have i done it will i do it again sure
but like i don't think we're supposed to
do these things i understand i get it i
know i'm not and it's just
i mean whenever i go skiing
i'll be like because my wife's like
it'll be good to expose them to
something they won't be able to afford
to do
um so it was
i'm always kind of like i i don't want
to break my leg i'm taping a special
internet i know what i'm doing in a week
you know so it's not like i can really
relax i went ice skating now never i
would never i swear it was like standing
on blades
it was really uncomfortable and i was
like i'm out yeah i would never i feel
like that's the things you got to do
young like if you didn't do that you got
a hat you can't learn as an adult it's
like riding a motorcycle you just got to
if you're going to ride a motorcycle you
have to start when you were like three
years old yeah
you start now you're you're in deep
trouble yeah all right i got one more
have you ever squeegee uh have you ever
used a squeegee at the gas station to
clean anything else but the windshield
yeah like part of the car yeah like the
doors and the hubcaps or something
come on
come on jim you can afford a detail the
dashboard the steering wheel
on the back the kids in the other kids
yeah no like and by the way i didn't own
a car for 30 years so oh right where you
were in this city and we would you had a
license though right you knew how to
drive i had a license so like when i
worked in la i would drive but now i
have a car
because i have five kids
it's a big one where i have to pay not
only parking but extra parking sure
svu charts yeah yes yeah they see it
coming it's brutal and whatever they
have posted it when you're like pulling
into the garage it's always like you
know 80 more than that or whatever yeah
no it's kind of like i go to this i have
to see the skin doctor every three
months and he just like whenever he sees
me he's like
money like i'm definitely paying for a
couple of
summer houses
a couple of kids going to harvard but
gang ladies and gentlemen
one hundred percent trash mr jones
you know by the way i feel like that's
uh that's an honor 100 100
and you know what the thing is is like i
have a joke about how
there's
moments when you think you're not when
you think you're high class when you're
you hang around some fancy people are
like you're like you know i got a couple
things in common with these people and
then you hang around trash with people
or you hear them behind you and you're
like i got a lot yeah these are my
people
yeah they're talking about jeans from
the 80s i get it
[Applause]
when you talk about roller skating
parties i know what they're talking
about oh man nothing like roller skating
rink pizza good night oh yeah oh the
best well you you will you take things
from the hotel the shampoos and stuff
like that i used to definitely used to
um i will also um
like if i get pizza for the kids
um or if i'll get pizza and it'll stay
in the room for a couple days and my
wife will be like should i i'm like
that's perfectly fine yeah yeah well you
leave it on the counter for multiple
days yeah room temperature pizza yeah i
love rooms mad man yeah
it's fine yes i couldn't agree more
where do you think you think cheese was
in a refrigerator in the 1800s yeah it's
already cooked and everything you're
fine at pizza hut back then though
yeah but it's just like it's also that's
where i'm a cheap bastard i'm like this
is perfectly fine you know an
eight-year-old they don't know the
difference between good or bad
food poisoning or non-food poisoning
e coli salmonella
ladies and gentlemen mr jim gaffigan
thank you sir do you have anything
coming up you want to know about
obviously we have a comedy monster is
that on netflix it is on netflix and um
i'm touring unless the world ends
i'm uh i'm gonna be back out there i'm
in chicago i'm in
uh rochester's a great trashy town there
you go have you had a garbage plate not
yet i hear goodbye oh my gosh um but
yeah so going all around i'm trying to
think of i can't you know like i did a
podcast the other day and with comics
and they listed all these cities off the
top of their head i'm like i don't know
where i'm going
but i mean you're doing foxy
boston
i'm doing a show in mexico city yeah i
just can't remember all that you know
and you have like 15 movies coming out
it's insane it's very fun hopefully i'll
get more it's awesome
we love you buddy thank you so much yeah
thank you what do you got for him uh
just you know at cameron social media at
cameron comedy check out our special on
youtube and our live dates uh should be
posted by the time this comes out so
check it out gang we love you we'll see
you next week